[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to Verona
welcome to GameSpot's indie mix
livestream I'm like my Hardy I'll be
hosting throughout the day we have a
couple hours of indie devs coming in
they're flying in from all over the
world to for GDC showing off their game
is gonna be doing some panels and
everything so we figured we have all
these intelligent people right down the
street from us here in San Francisco why
not bring them in and show off their
game I'm here with Petri and you came
here from New York yesterday or Y a few
days ago but you're working out of
Finland yes we're working with a guy
named Ali who made the swapper but you
yourself made cram physics deluxe yes
now you teamed up on the game that we're
about to see each game we're gonna play
for about 20 minutes
today we're gonna be playing Noah which
is which one one of the ones I'm really
excited about it's kind of right up my
alley as far as rogue lights go but yeah
like I hope how's your GDC week go and
so far I guess it just started right
like it very much like I I picked that
my badge and my speaker back and they
also have to come here so we got you
before you're all tired out with and
everything yeah I hope so yeah I have to
travel so cool
well let's jump right in I don't want to
waste too much time so this is Noah give
me like the elevator pitch what kind of
game is it what can we expect as we're
playing well originally the name of the
game later as we were working on it it
was called wizard physics and our
marketing department which is I mean
yeah one of us figure it out if that's
not gonna be the best name for this game
it's like a V selling so we figure out
what this awesome name Noida which no
one can pronounce okay I know but yeah
but who is it physics essentially tells
you why you do in this game so it's like
there's physics okay
it means we have this custom engine and
all of the we're essentially simulating
all the pixels in the game and they have
like physical properties okay so for
example here you see here are some
lanterns and if I shoot at them they
will leak some oil guys and then they
will start burning okay and if I hang
around too much like there's some water
here but I hang around in the oil I'll
probably get covered in oil and then
I'll
not asleep okay cool so wait so you're
like more flammable yeah okay cool
and then we have essentially other
things so the other part of it is like
your wizard and you making casts and do
spells and then essentially what you do
in this game it's a action rope life so
you're trying to essentially get as deep
as possible and these caverns which are
procedurally generated okay so and what
that means is this is gonna be it's
gonna be over if I die so that bill I
guess the rope as a road like you do
carry over some progression between
at the moment there is there's some of
that okay in the plans but there's not
that much of a currently in the game
so essentially what will happen if what
if I die is if it's gonna be hit so yeah
this guy's son he's also leaking this
poisonous radioactive material okay and
if I if I touch it that was gonna damage
me but luckily no I thought I've gotten
fire
okay where'd that fire come from was
there a lantern yeah thank you
I think that guy busted two lantern up I
mean this is all wood so it's burning
yeah I got that guy ah this is looking
bit nasty to get back I'll try to not
touch that stuff you have unlimited like
thrust for that I know it's here trust
is here here's my HP is I'm already at
six days I'm not going to well but
you're saying you're more of a patient
kind of player I am conservative I I
tried to play conservatively okay I'm
kind of I'm usually like that
something like Robo legacy or risk of
rain yeah it's especially like when it's
a perma debt share do you like so I for
example you can you can munch some blood
to give you a few long but that give you
what does that do that currently doesn't
do that much okay it looks better than
us yeah so I will try and make it get to
the to a little bit of progress here so
we get to actually see what's happening
so the other weapon I have here or magic
wand I have here is the set of a wing
that generates these huge balls that
destroys all the environments
[Applause]
is there any specific games that you
guys looked at as far as inspiration i
mean i spelunky robe legacy come to mind
for me
yes belong key different Elizabeth
everyone's for us we've played a lot of
spelunk yeah there are some other games
which was like probably I don't know if
people know that there's a game called
me arrow which is a finish finished
shareware a game from I think 1999 or
something okay
it's like real-time words they
essentially go and you destroy
everything in it gotcha
so one of the things here is like here
is this huge pool of lava
alright doubt I will be able to get on
the other side too right now but there
could be a way let's see is it like a
dynamic soundtrack it sounds like the
music or is that just like timing it
kicked in it is somewhat dynamic at that
moment it's like the trombones it's not
like trumpets maybe brass kicks in now
we got the music from van call from
grotto whose potential band it's okay
this is a huge pool of oil okay and
here's a exploding box if I shoot that
I'm just gonna set all this on fire
elephant really did the problem is I'm
covered in oil which makes me extremely
I have a bowl but I will try I get to
the other side here without dying
so what aspects of the game that doesn't
look like an enemy you want to face
right now
this is cool there's as this the case
with some rogue lights there's bad luck
every once in a while right yeah there
are these guys and they're screening
your errands area but apparently one of
them appeared here right away yeah it's
really cool big Z he ends up eating
everything and you can actually get some
fat waste through that but also very
dangerous
I will not go there yet huh
so is there like a risk reward factor
and spelunky like in spelunky we you
know like you have to kind of decide
whether to keep staying in an area and
gathering coal different items or just
like get through it is does that come
into play here as well yeah okay so when
you kill enemies you see they drop gold
get right get here and I have my HP and
my HP I mean obviously a fight if I lose
HP I will die okay I'm trying to get
like here is a pickup this will give me
some heart containers okay so if I pick
this up when I have more yeah
oh so that's maximum health is now
increased but the actual health hasn't
this guy seems kind of nasty let me deal
with them using this exploding barrel I
drop it there and actually ask let's
blow tit and kill those things just do
it this guy okay I think that's gonna
burn and hopefully explored at some
point area okay is that poison or just a
big bad this is a big vat of poison
actually and let's see if we can explode
that and get that guy covered in poison
and using fire it's funny because like I
mean it's a gorgeous game but like the
physics is so much more involved than
you might think just from looking at
screenshots or something yeah like right
there that yeah let's see it alright
he's covered in poison assuming that's
just damage over time yeah this is also
a bit dangerous luckily he's dead yeah
so there's another wand here that I
could pick up
I fill these guys first I'd be like your
third weapon yes fourth in this case I
have here at once which we cool
oh so my plan was actually so what you
get is you get these wands from levels
you also get some gold hopefully and one
serious sort of hopefully done and you
oh my god oh that's nasty
okay I made it so then you get to these
this teleport and what this teleport
does is it teleports you in this area
and poisoned but luckily if I give
myself into this water it will heal it
so when you get here you get this heart
and this will give you back all your
health so now I'm actually back at 125
and then you get to the shop to shop
parkour where you can buy things okay
which dance would be cool unfortunately
too expensive so
especially electrocution field it sounds
useful and so when you actually get here
then you get to modify your wands and
make your own spells out of these so
unfortunately I don't have too much
stuff now but you get more into progress
in the game so now as I put this
electrocution field into this wand so
now when I when I fire this it'll it'll
create this field and electrocute
anything in it okay so luckily I am nice
to it so we will go and try and use that
in the next area I was like an AoE
attack yeah cool so usually what happens
is when you get here
this place collapses so you can't get
back but remember that worm that just
happens to be on there that allows to
have this back door hinges on this area
so that actually worked out the fact
that yes my stuff yeah with that portal
go to another no it ghost is the same
place there okay cool so almost one
point and if I go there then I'm
probably somewhat stuck maybe I can
explode this possibly but I will not
hopefully go there but I could go now
actually go back and get some better
stuff cuz I won't actually do some bit
of progress that's not gonna necessarily
happen every time right that one I want
to show up
no that's extremely rare for that guys
happen up there and we lucked out this
week yeah so here's here's a chest that
do you see a bunch of gold so that
allows me to find more things okay you
can see that worm guy has been busy in
this area yeah pain like this is a nest
that spawns these guys that shoot these
fire balls now I'm fire luckily get some
water so okay we do how long would you
burn if there wasn't water it's not
definite no it depends like if I'm
covered in something flammable then I
will burn right up longer
she said you're a pretty conservative
player as far as taking your time goes
is there anything stopping you from
taking as much time as you want in each
area gathering everything no not really
you can you could take I mean the thing
that's stopping you from doing that is
it is deadly out here not just by means
of the enemy but the environment is
deadly like here if I'm not paying
attention this fire didn't sort of come
here and second my it's a neon fire yeah
that's gonna be a huge pain there are
also like Oh super seeing I mean you say
you're inspired by spelunky of course
and I think like any Grove like nowadays
is going to be in some way because of
how influential it was but the systemic
stuff that comes out of these
environmental effects just it seems
super unique as far as what you're doing
and that's really cool because even like
you look at Triple A games nowadays and
like what's the most recent Zelda is
even going for that emergent systems
kind of gameplay oh yeah and how things
interact and that's really cool to see
it and you know like in a roguelike oh
yeah yeah that has been one of those
things that's really just be really cool
working on this games all the sort of
crazy like that I mean I'm assuming is
do you have any I mean not maybe not
specific anecdotes but any plan any time
I hear developer making some game with
like in our lab in systems like they
always see stuff that they didn't even
know if it happened yeah well we had at
the beginning of the working process we
have like these tears that would be
moving around if and then we added that
the deer's would know they don't have to
eat something so they learned around and
eating some grass and why not yeah and
they'd get they would have to go and
take a piss and we simulated that so
there he pissed scumming out of there
and but what we didn't realize is that
they will go into bottom of like here
then go down here and then pee around
and they would drown in their own pee oh
my gosh and found all his dead deer
everywhere that's around in their own
pee
have you gotten a chance to play much
door fortress I have not it's not about
the drunk cats yeah yeah I know exactly
what you're talking about that's a game
I really should I really should play but
I also know like like the epitome of
like inner laughing systems are complex
level that's really hold on that's
something like that exists in this game
so so the enemies don't pee anymore okay
that's good
what is this pink fluid this pink fluid
is slime and if I get stuck in it I will
be very slow
gotcha and you can use that to your
advantage to get your enemies stuck in
there okay there's a treasure chest that
you can see a bunch of gold so what's
your ultimate goal like it say you have
a successful run what do you have to do
you have to be at the end well you have
to find this magical thing that is at
the end of it and there's a bunch of
these lowers here currently I think we
have about eight of them here okay I
don't know what is gonna be in the game
of Achilles and it's gonna might change
okay
depending on that but let's see if we
can make it to the next one the next
one's kind of cool okay
there's the portal and you've got less
200 gold yeah go we'll see what we can
buy with that and there's more let's go
let's go
how many how many different like
personal items are there or effects it
looks like there's a lot if there is a
lot I actually don't know the exact
amount how I knew it so could you
combine something with the electrocution
field so you just start ok mixing and
matching yeah so even there the systems
start coming like this start flashing
with each other or not clashing but
cover yeah yeah you can get like create
Bree that's awesome very interesting
things here cool unfortunately we didn't
get anything that dad shown here we
wouldn't want to show off everything
yeah téa's it so well these things
always play out the same order like
mines holy mountain snowy depth yes so
you kind of have like doesn't know
what's happening here so in this area
there's a bunch of ice and snow and I
can I can crack this ice here cool with
that damage someone if the fell on them
yes if I can get in here okay see this
is kind of interesting
mm-hmm oh you got you hit your max
inventory or what yeah because then I
have to select which things I keep but
we will see what this one does I'm not
actually 100% certain okay
it's shooting up these guys that are
know you're smoking it you're still
controlling the projectile if you shoot
it looks like no it's that projectile is
seeking enemies oh it's actually going
going around
oh okay fire I can notice I'm the same
worm huh are these tunnels from the same
worm for they saw weight is very
possible it's the same word that's
really cool speed just be busy okay so
that could either lead you to some
cooler areas or screw you over
Oh oh my god yes I am probably going to
die here soon I might actually no
perfect timing I mean what an epic all
right let's slice like trying Oh try and
use this okay let's see if we can rush
it so that like obviously you probably
wouldn't have rushed as much if okay
awesome thing well that's actually
unfortunately all the time we have but
uh Petric notches are showing on noise
ah anything else so like it's gonna be
in early access you don't have a
specific date or no you know yeah but
you are working on it with ollie and
yeah and you'll be showing it off at GDC
this week and everything will you get
the indie mixed stream tonight by any
chance yes I hope you guys see you there
then as well but uh yeah like this is a
great game to kick it off I love her
like so I know a lot of my audience
those too but uh thank you so much it
for coming in and showing on thank you
for having us yeah absolutely and is fun
but uh everybody watching we will be
right back we are gonna be showing black
future 88 we'll have like five more
games we're gonna show today until 1
p.m. Pacific but thank you so much for
joining and stick around we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's grate some terrible names so hey
everyone how's it going we are back with
black feature 88 I'm here with Zack and
Don and I'm Mike if you're just joining
again we are gonna be playing a bunch of
indie games some some of the more
exciting ones that we wanted to show off
throughout the week here at GDC as we
have a bunch of these really talented
intelligent designers here in San
Francisco right down the street from so
how's it going so gone really really
yeah
yes it you're just that just got in one
like yesterday or you just actually I
live here at my Oakland a loafer myself
so yeah so you didn't have to come
through far but anyway we are gonna be
playing black future 88
so I guess elevator pitch sack or add-on
I guess is actually gonna be playing a
kind of angle most question Athan but
obviously feel free to chime in whatever
go so pitch me black future 88 while
we're getting into air show so black
future idiot is a brutal cyberpunk
roguelike but the way that it's a
roguelike and the way that cyberpunk
might kind of surprise a lot of people
and so every you only have 18 minutes to
live before your heart explodes so yeah
that just like you know an everyday life
action game non-fiction game it's kind
of cyberpunk in the vein more along like
Robocop Robocop 2 we've got the morality
system a road cop - okay
so his ex playing the new character
ghost which has the black nail which
basically kind of freezes time a little
bit when it's lost okay um and also uh
teleports it basically swaps places with
whatever you shoot and it close up your
enemy it looks like uh yeah there's the
ghost is also a very low health
character he's probably got the electron
pistol yeah I guess yeah reductive oh
you got the X 20 V X 20 is one of our
favorite future drugs from 1988 what's
in the game yeah there's actually a
pretty complex drug addiction mechanic
in the game where if you do too many
drugs your health bar gets infected and
it might it might explode if you take
damage to one of those squares yeah okay
yeah but of course the drugs also have
buffs in the time you take them yeah
exactly and they're either temporary
they usually last until you take damage
so it's just kind of a way of kind of
optimizing you know do you do go for
immediate but cheap power versus you
know longer-lasting but more aggressive
power okay cool so who said it you said
it might be surprising how you use
cyberpunk in this game yeah you know for
me I think film is a really big
reference I this is gonna be really off
the wall but the dance scene from the
running man yes that's kind of informed
a large part of the game that's all you
had to say enough soul I've got a damn
steam from running man so yeah
unfortunately the dancing wasn't in the
book but it should have been
maybe they'll do a sequel with the
dancing in it here's hoping okay awesome
so that's like the aesthetic yeah I know
one for Aussie yeah but you climb a
procedural tower it's cool it's insane
toner you only have 18 minutes to live
but it's kind of tracked more like a
football time so kind of sobs it starts
I guess 16 20 up there I see younger
than ya your health and blue
yeah his health there's a little money
counter there dashing is a really
primary mechanic in the game so you can
dash through walls no that not in this
build you have to upgrade that yeah so
as you kill bosses you get to upgrade
your - okay and you get to eventually
weaponize it and you get to have more
dashes longer dashes faster - is laser
dashes so that's either gun the black
nail ran out of ammo okay so when a gun
runs out of ammo it turns into a melee
weapon and you can basically Club things
to death with it
but it still has like its properties
that it had so since that was a
teleporting railgun you'll still swap
places with things okay so you can hit
them from underneath the platform and
pop up like right next to them or swap
places with them so it's it's kind of
used you can actually escape and engage
really quickly with it okay yeah sure
tunnels there you go so we're gonna
start unlocking stuff because we're
gonna however there is progress from
yeah okay cool that's like the Rope
light element I guess it's not a grindy
like how some games sure kind of make
you grind out kind of persistent power
yeah as you play the game it's still
perma death but you unlock things that
can now happen in the tower okay and
it's not necessarily more powerful it's
usually just more complicated okay I see
it if you actually go to quit run yeah
go to quit well until he's a different
character like fast
yeah there are individual characters
yeah five ghost ghost is kind of work in
progress and is very perfectionist
driven okay we do the daily challenge
but where is DeLorean
yeah well it's actually Marvel F 2 of
the toyota mr2 which is a kind of best
car ever made in terms of aesthetics
sort of yeah yeah so so you're actually
gonna play a suit which is C was a drug
dealer or drug addict I'm gonna start
with some interesting bus oh the rocket
launcher is a great way to get yourself
killed
okay yeah raka raka weapons are a
high-risk high-reward but mostly
high-risk others secret right there say
he's a he's a drug addict yeah so you
can see a suit wanted suits health bars
I'm just really having a hard time okay
yeah so if you get if that if you lose
that you're done yeah you'll take a lot
of damage and it'll likely kill you what
is that drug with the positive effect of
this drug addiction that he has um you
get to talk to the drug dealer for free
oh and so Zach actually hook up yeah he
found a secret portal okay so the tower
itself is cursed
it's the the story of is basically this
AI contraption come to life into the
tower and it was built by the main boss
of the game Duncan okay but it turns out
the tower itself is alive and is
actually like the true final boss okay
cool
so yeah it is a fairly difficult game
that's kind of the difficulty is along
the lines of binding of issac so sure I
was gonna say like I was thinking
binding of issac us thinking spelunky I
guess as far as like what kind of games
influence you guys on making us I think
a game like I think from a feel was a
really big starting point so I actually
once I got like beyond the systems
oh you should free I'm gonna go left
because yeah I need to take that room
out of down so from for me game feel was
really the starting point for a lot of
things after kind of the prototype had
proven itself out so I kind of followed
the forty blam beer tip level you
exploded yourself to that your blood
exploded so obviously it's a challenging
game
yeah oh you didn't rank too high in the
dailies it's about your most the planet
number one yeah yeah so I the the
Vlambeer forty tips for a cool action
game was a really good starting cloche
area and then I kind of came up with
like 20 more things that I thought were
really important to the black future
game okay
so I've kind of pushed the idea of feel
as far as I think I can take it cool
that's brother fun can there any like
those tenants like what can you on a
name like maybe a oh yeah for me kind of
slowing down time is the thing that I
take very seriously so it I use it
really differently on a lot of weapons
there's about like each weapon has maybe
40 or 50 different attributes yeah so
when you shoot something you know
there's knock back there's recoil
there's ammo use it might stall you in
the air for a little bit so you can kind
of slow down your own rate of fall okay
I might freeze time and for me time is
really always gonna be the central core
thing of the game that makes it unique I
mean the clocks literally ticking yeah
yeah in some rooms the time of stock
like when you're in a shop or an upgrade
menu like there's no reason yes that
should be a thoughtful choice so don't
make it stressful
okay the players oh that's a drug of the
VX 21 of the best drugs in the world
so now Zak's rate of fire and damage is
much faster and he has one point of
armor
but if he if he takes damage he'll lose
is the x.25 gosh so yeah there's a lot
of curse items in the game
Oh so let me let me actually back up the
tower actually upgrades itself so as you
leave stuff on the ground like money or
ammo the tower makes itself stronger
Singh that likes supposedly be using it
in my house yeah so it'll actually
release hunters to come out and find you
and they're all named and they have
names that might ring a bell if you've
seen the Running Man
yeah are not actually taking for the
Running Man there are things like
barrage okay a kind of American
Gladiator theme sure laser and taser and
exactly okay so the game world is made
from five continuous zones so there's
not really any loading screens once you
get into the game yeah so that's that
kind of stasis pistol which is a a an
energy weapon that makes things fall
when you hit them okay so it's pretty
neat a lot of content is highly
interactive with each other yeah I was
just saying noticing it I mean there I
mean it immediately is aesthetically
pleasing and I'd like you'd like you
said that's slowing down time and the
platform itself looks like it would just
feel good but it looks like there are a
lot of systems interacting right now
that you that are not immediately
apparent until you understand the game
yeah exactly it's simple to learn
difficult to master but even like even
so there seems like it's a lot going on
that I would need to dig into
yeah and that's part of how the
unlocking stuff works because there's
actually a lot of complicated weapons
that do things like one of the guns
actually uses time as the Tama source
yes super strong but using it is
literally killing you so oh does it take
away from your overall that clock yeah
that's yes so guys it's time as its ammo
resources the Juno and Jupiter boss
fight that's gonna die
it's good it's a robot and it's yeah
it's kind of a boy in the dog dynamic
where the dog is a giant machine named
after a classic synthesizer sure and the
boy is a giant man named after classic
synthesizer okay Juno and Jupiter I was
gonna mention this soundtrack is awesome
oh thanks that's my band we're trimmer
low we're from the Bay Area and we play
law shows sweet so this the soundtrack
has been a really big project for us
yeah and we're starting to play these
songs live that's off work she have the
DNA lounge tomorrow night obviously
black features that cool that's that's
good for anyone EDC right oh yeah yeah
it's so poor to ative huh go ahead so
instead oh so it was like we worked on
it yeah sir that you might do it you
might do a episode you might do it why
don't you better using it look it looks
like a lightsaber I have to say yeah you
know it's energy it's a beam weapon
right energy sword so uh since he killed
Gianna really cool they got you know he
enraged Jupiter customers didn't want to
CNN smog boss fight from Dark Souls 1 oh
right hey that boss fight was a huge
kind of design reference for how this
one might work okay even though the game
systems are wholly different
so what are you gonna get so we're gonna
get to that
oh that's the juban our signature buff
it's pretty good but are you get a
choice of which one didn't use it yeah
there's kind of a random assortment you
only get to pick one in each boss has
its own particular one so if you kill
Jupiter that's the only way to get the
that one Tex is very salty I was just i
noticed before that went away I love the
names of those upgrades like second
thoughts remorse suppressor yeah
emotional things yeah it's it's oh dude
he only gives you raw deals but do you
do it it's Hilux safe he looks friendly
he looks oh you got the night piercer
that's the best one that's the best
thing you could have gotten so now you
can - actually through platforms and you
can just really be the the assassin eros
meant to be sweet so and you got the the
cooldown buff so and now your dash is
much faster yeah all right it's been
like pretty just fortuitous upgrades
yeah less you know he's having a pretty
lucky run I'd say there's there's
actually a secret combo system in the
game try not to put numbers on the
screen but so the sequence optimizer
this I think it means your your guns
don't take em oh if your combo levels
four or above yeah so don't don't get
hit yeah so your your combo level is
actually the amount of smoke that's on
you
so as you kill things quickly and don't
take damage you're the smoke around the
player okay I'm just like real life
yeah it's can't even remember the amount
of time but that's how
the realism sound is just oh yeah
as a father into a four and a half year
old this is basically every day yeah
it's a model laughter my everyday
experience you might not even have to
like teach him or her anything Chanel
buy the game and understand yeah she's
like oh yeah oh don't know what was
coming for you student of drugs this
game just feels like a cocaine acid trip
yeah it looks like I wouldn't know I'm
just saying like me I don't know
anything about that but yeah I think
that as like the color goal is basically
guardians of the galaxy too but makes it
Lisa Frank haven't seen I want it you
know in the game yeah so goals so Dynamo
is gonna come for you in a room or two
Dino is not gonna be your friend but
Dynamo always drops a weapon so yeah
that's why it is dynamo hunter Dinah was
a hunter gotcha
so like that you're going I mean I don't
know if this is intentional or not but
most these kind of games you're going
down and the ones I'm thinking of you're
descending this one they're the opposite
yeah it's pretty much the only building
left of any purpose in the world and
you're going up there to destroy you
it's kind of personal nihilism then
fulfills how I you know it describes how
a parent my mentality I'm gotcha so very
like a semi-autobiographical
stuff that exactly it's gonna be the
next one
yeah oh the skull icon oohs points away
the boss is s dynamo that sign well just
come in to be a cheer yeah he's coming
for you oh man always come for you
[Music]
so between the laser and the the actual
like bulbous projectile you're like a
secondary primary right now yeah you
only have two weapons only the Paycheck
is really good the names of these things
are so good ah the Paycheck in sync with
nature oh you took yeah yeah yeah so the
Paycheck that actually uses your money
as this ammo source shotguns pretty good
yeah so it's extremely powerful but
using it
oh you didn't get it now that Tower is
gonna upgrade itself yeah so you only
have a little bit to pick up things on
the ground before the tower eat it okay
we really want the tower to feel alive
and sure working on it yeah yeah so
weird like you mentioned earlier this is
a very very weird reference um you know
movie in theaters or an hour I think it
just left annihilation oh I haven't seen
it by here it's a excellent book it's
based off of has it has this thing that
like a lot of people well I don't want
to spoil anything but there's about
living is how are they they descend into
really yeah it's just weird to hearing
you say this over and over and I'm
thinking like I wish I could talk about
that more but I doubt many people have
read it oh man but yeah you just see
we'll get something it's really good so
you want a Netflix like oh really yeah
paramount so listen that witch or
something almost yeah no oh you got
troubles um yeah I'm gonna oh my god
prophet five classic synthesizer man Bay
Area so good so first of all really so
there's your first wait Juno and Jupiter
wasn't the first boss that's the first
one we did oh yeah that's my second boss
Roger random but they actually get
harder the later you encounter them okay
right now they just have more health but
they're gonna be more aggressive they're
gonna shoot more balls and they're also
gonna have new abilities the later you
find them in the game okay
similar to Binding of Isaac but I think
we're gonna really double down on new
possibilities sure a little stuck in the
ha
nice you only roll this is the best
friend I've ever done
yeah so you're about to enter the power
center which has come a very
experimental area
okay we've set it up so now you have two
dashes so now that's what second
thoughts is yeah so you have two little
so how would you is it easy to say right
now maybe you don't know but like nine
minutes left is that good on time for
the point you're at he's doing pretty
well he probably needs to hurry up
though yeah I need to get on this plan
we're playing a double jump in double
dash nice Oh power centered Zach just
bright at that I know three days ago
yeah yeah that's exactly say I'm
assuming you do like the art yeah um we
have it's a really small team we have
about three or four people working on
the game okay and that started doing the
initial concept thing of the to the
concept art okay and then I lately we've
kind of moved out of concept and really
just in the production and sex they do
it's really good spriting work what kind
of as far as your portfolio goes without
weird some past experience some past
projects you've worked on myself yeah I
was at kicks I really early on so I
worked on a lot of games of kicks and
they were kind of mobile mid core but
then I spent about three years working
on a mobile call tom okay and we we have
fought in the mobile Wars valiantly but
like many people except are like two
games yeah yeah you know we're not we're
not donut we're not long yeah that's
kind of speaks for itself yeah so MOBAs
are really hard to make and kind of a
system design it kind of really informed
the black future systems like okay in
terms of like I know
architecture and sharing day but this is
really my first time as an indie and I
okay really into it cool this is my
first project like out of color truly
alright I'm really thankful to be picked
up by Dawn it's awesome
where do you live in the area as well
Zack no I'm actually from I went to
school in Baltimore okay I went to mica
and so I was you know traveling the
country to come see this thing straight
music is really awesome I think a lot it
means right up my alley - I mean I yeah
try to I think for me like perturbator
not exactly like what he does but how he
does it share a huge reference like
really go for distortion risers
everything is saturated like to the
nines shouldn't bring it up if I the
name is escaping me but one of his songs
there's a music video for it that's
unreal it's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
figure it yourselves
it's like the spaceships that hard
shaped like crucifixes and then it's
this dude like breaking this girl out of
this prison and driving around and not
like a 69 Corvette is that is that turbo
killer is that what that is yeah man a
brute carpenter brut yeah there's some
Albert debate awesome leather teeth yes
not a thank you that was carpenter brut
what was funny about leather teeth is
they did this is so random they did a
tour promo video not for the album just
for the tour they're doing it's just
like the European Legos her but it was a
sick live action from a video yeah with
this character that's like all metal
face that's like actually a really
strong character reference for some of
the new work pretty good guys like dude
this is so sick
this guy's so metal so yeah I just got a
mix about the shows how much I really
know but I think they were at DNA lounge
maybe a couple years ago or something
yeah that's not coordinator at DNA I am
he's gonna be a DNA yeah we're playing
yeah ain't safe G&A it's actually like a
huge career point for us office yeah and
that's tomorrow night yeah cool yeah I
mean I try to go that looks fun yeah
yeah Ben frontiers playing which is also
really fast you know I and to the breach
yeah they're not going into the breach
yet I
really good I really can't wait to get I
keep seeing people just like on Twitter
amazed at it oh you're gonna pull the
switch so you actually you can actually
pull a switch and ask for a hunter to
come into the game okay and that's kind
of more advanced tactic so that you can
really try to get a good weapon oh yeah
look that's for competent players and
Zakia nothing if not a confident player
so I'm only mentioning comparison to
Dark Soul because you brought up earlier
everybody compares like things that Dark
Souls yeah that kind of seems like the
Darcys invasion system yeah yeah very
very much like it but that that is
actually very much straight lifted from
the movie running man okay abs
everyone's cheering oh yeah yeah yeah oh
man I need to go back and watch that
again well you know really that's that's
like the Elora I would say ready man
yeah I watched this super oh you got the
new boss here I'm just due to run for
your life yeah I know
I'll just stay away from home this is
the newest boss we just kind of finished
him off I love a few days ago and it's
this is kind of a new high-water mark
for yo boss design in the game work what
was that like droid that just hit you
did he should have yeah he mostly fights
with drones drones at you and you have
to kind of manage the mess he's making
while trying to do damage to him before
he makes some more drones would they
drop ammo which is nice yeah so they're
like the
yeah
too badly like yeah too bad leaves yeah
dude we just keep spawning more and more
drones if you're not yeah really guys
Keva it's kind of this yeah I don't know
if you've ever worked at a summer camp
with small children but um it's similar
it's gonna you don't if you don't put
all the kids up in time they just yeah
it's gonna keep fighting it's a numbers
game and you're on the losing side what
actually might be good timing yeah
unfortunately that might be all the time
I have right now but yeah damn I should
take a deep breath after watching that
game we go bird non-stop intensity it's
awesome so black feature 88 Don and Zach
won like can we play this as the
audience um later this year cool okay
yeah I'm late
will there be any like it will it be an
early access she's gonna release it no
we're working with Good Shepherd and
we're not doing an early access pace but
I think we actually have a lot of
post-launch content okay I'm really
excited about cool and that'll be like
releasing periodically I'm assuming
afterward yeah and I think we're we're
currently looking at some consoles but
we don't have anything in announced
right now okay so I think right now PC
yeah we're launching for some PC and
awesome Donna and Zach thanks so much
for coming on showing black featuring
Mike yeah have a good show tomorrow yeah
have a good rest of the week at GDC
congratulations of all it looks like an
awesome game I'm looking forward to
playing this I think really fun to watch
and play and everything so thanks again
yeah the rest week and everybody if
you're watching right now stick around
we'll be back on right after the break
we're gonna be coming out with like
about four more developers show off
their games and stick around we'll see
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to GameSpot's
indie mix livestream I'm Mike my Hardy
thank you so much for joining we are
showing off games here in town for GDC
I'm here with Sebastian open from Warsaw
Poland he's gonna be showing us carry on
so I'm excited for this
you made early before you made a
platformer shooter with debris working
on the platformer sugar the difficult
what was the your previous project
butcher butcher and that was super hard
everybody was super super skill base
there super fast place and etc yeah
can we expect some of that in carrion
not really yes it's a more like yeah
we're gonna get right into that physical
physicals days game okay so you see it's
a it's a bit oh man ok so you got these
tendrils kind of it's not it's not you
don't need to be as precise ok culture
so more I understand you're kind of
absorbing like eating humans of course
and you're growing in sizes you go you
can see you travel through tight okay
vents to Mel's and you can scare the
people study people that we try to look
you lock themselves but you can just
creep or whatever so yeah it's like a
horror game but you are dancing this is
reverse horror you don't fear that yeah
you'd instead of to the fear you instill
it in others at us
and so how many people total on a team
are you working on so far it's three
people okay it with my beautiful
if gotcha if we ever give some details
okay you were just everywhere now so did
you grow its size and you ate them
yes okay awesome I can see we were about
how the size you know okay so can you
know explore oh it's different different
different obstacle I can't pass it the
straight through me like now I'm in some
skill gotcha
sometimes like I mean we need to go back
feel okay it's not like you're kind of
like looking for upgrades to use the
monster says looking for upgrades okay
we're looking to our aim is to escape
the facility and find the spot to grow
hype those animations are very soft see
some some glitches I need to fix it yeah
so what is there like backstory to where
you are is this earth is this some other
planet or is just this is this is a this
is on the side of the earth okay so yeah
there are some variants I would rather
let's talk about and share alike because
you know things might change Aaron also
the interaction with objects is excused
right now I can open the regular prayer
so if I can say that so humans any
danger T the ones with guns I'm assuming
is Larry you guys have girls and they
come shoot me okay
I can approach them from from different
hiding spots okay
torture
hey we've read the their heads off okay
naturally yeah some photos this is the
master featuring this is the parrot okay
I can tell especially because I get
shocked okay and it starts to stick with
me a lot away okay so introduction is
I'm using a mouse sure is there any way
to destroy that tears I just all
avoiding it you can maybe not this in
this level but you could disable the
turret added to some some puzzles like
switches maybe some other future
gameplay feature so you can do that so
by eating these humans and growing in
size is that giving you any gameplay
advantages or you is it just making
decisive gives you more co above you are
slightly more clunky okay no more
vulnerable yeah you can see I can only
11 health but if I feed the human eye
can replenish the health also and my max
health will increase what is just
everywhere or something that we have we
have 66 max those race by sex with that
we grow we grow one so okay
there are other types of eminences will
sentry drones
[Applause]
they were local shoot-off you can grab
my memories so it's a all interactions
are fully physical yeah I can do that
that's awesome
today we are about to get the the skill
we need to proceed further so yeah
so physical interaction this is the
container and you just rip do okay so
this is the progress skill is that the -
you needed to get through those other
mattress internal walls okay
grabbing just you just can do it bends
because there are weak sure so now we
ended up would you say there's something
like a Metroidvania aspect to this game
so yes also we think about sort of the
Zelda approach becomes two level design
I think we are not decided we're not
this decided about that and it's
possible to do that we will have
separate separate levels like Don
Johnson soda and the overworld and the
different kinds kinds of overall okay so
you know you can like backtrack and it
will be an interesting experience
because it will change in time shares
now you don't fall as you progress you
know all this stuff yeah
you shouldn't force your way through
that wall yeah I had to try sign it
oh you see that's the part is dead ah
then kill me
cool so yeah I try to speed round yeah
okay cool well so is the frame rate is
pretty low and I connected to the HDMI
okay yeah I can just play a little I
notice on bleach the level design the
same from time to time or is it
procedural it's a it's made by hand but
okay you can sub partially personally a
personal reason right it is okay well so
it's not everything that's place check
by designer
or interactions allow you want this game
to be very interactive and fun so you
can choose what to do a lot of those
physics this physics is very simple
yeah but yeah of course the effect of
that is also of the we want to make the
controls us sir
oh it's very easy to type you rock as a
turret yeah of those turrets and that's
a flamethrower guy too and another
abdomen of my own momentum to go yeah
yeah as you say it seems like momentum
does play a part expression you're like
throwing events and doors and so I can I
can destroy the hanging lights I can
just run away from the some other
strings from that oh yeah what does the
speedrunning suspect maybe about that
she feels just a so when do you have I
was the ultimate goal for this monster
that you're testing I guess also
undecided but I think it would be
something about being trapped in
societal facility the sighting facility
or something like that
and you have to run away or and just
survive so you prey on people on
anything else and something like that
okay
only one home because I don't eat
anything
oh crap it's like mom I'm back so one
more time this time I want that the
flames are got I got you it looked like
yeah I think my flamethrower
I like how you go like you start on the
menu screen and then move off of it or
at least in this bill that look thank
you that's what you're doing I just said
press the shooting Buffalo okay those
guys keep getting ambushed right in the
bathroom it looks like those toilets
might be that's mafia but yeah the
August thing is surely to be consider
yeah like they've tried to lure you into
the place where you will close them okay
but it's it's just we decided this in
the future part of the development
[Music]
so that's vanity health so I can run
through them fairly at hopelessly they
without being scared it's interesting
that it's kinda like a power fantasy
we're here the monster and just killing
everyone but then also there is still
danger involved with the turrets and the
flamethrowers there yeah sure where
everything that makes you happy able
this game
yeah toughest close what was that I was
at the flamethrower
yeah well we can do it quickly to be
gotcha what Center I just tried to spit
on the game with Lance it's not that we
shall show the end of the level
okay so there's like it's divided into
levels no it's just a single level so
I'm gonna get a decision you can go to
that you know like I said before we
still undecided to go fully Metroidvania
yeah or more divided way and values
little the dungeon or ever wealthy or
Mario
so can they can hear you before you come
in yes I can hear me and they they just
turn around and try to here we go okay
here we go
can you area we are dissolving the water
to a swarm of wolves if we use a little
later suddenly you just became like a
different kind of organism in the water
it's something like this okay
maybe Adafruit maybe this is the same
biomass about Havana is differently
because of water share it some guys to
replenish the house eating is just as
you can see they they hang with us under
sailing because they heard some gunshots
and and eating so calmly
[Music]
let's go about it
so yeah now I can pass through that I
hope you get that right it's got that
big huge now yeah here and now I can
utilize the water potential because you
can see I can pass through that place if
I'm a solid alright no problem
okay we're almost there okay so what
kind of things in the game are you
personally working on are you give
someone working on the art and then
you're like oh yeah what'd you say I'm
working under our but more importantly I
work on little design cool no matter the
time sorry programming oh hang on design
guy is also the reason I'm sorry that's
all right I just want to take all the
credit
so I saw the water raised so then the
world already saw me do follow me two
postulates Oh
oh my god okay we are there dead in the
correct place to spread our hive so we
just rub it okay
something like as of now the ejectives
just keep growing keep growing and reach
the correct place to put zero you
priceless biomass
okay Trish is a biomass not just as
carrion thank you so much the bastion
for coming and showing off the game
it'll be at the indie mix stream tonight
you look for your watching that I have
yeah and go if you happen to be around
go check out carrion and then I'll
you'll be here for the week for GDC in
San Francisco to probably cool awesome
and thanks so much for coming in and
yeah we really appreciate you showing
off the game looks great I'm a fan of
horror games so I like the idea of
playing from the other side of it as the
monster has to deal with
I will fool the fun with the frame of
games yeah awesome well thank you
everybody who joined to watch and if you
are watching stick around we're gonna
take a short break and bring on the next
team we're gonna show off another game
and thanks so much for joining and we'll
see you then thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
indie mix livestream I'm Mike my Hardy
here and we are showing you a bunch of
the coolest games coming out of GDC this
week while they're all in San Francisco
I'm here with Steve Philby from motion
twin how you go man good
I'm sure as opposed to the first few
games we've shown today a lot of people
will be familiar with dead cells because
it's been an early access and it kind of
uh obviously drew a lot of attention
just I mean I played a lot of it myself
between oh it's like I mean maybe a
roguelike game in general but also just
like the progress you're taking through
its platforming in combat but you guys
you're getting ready to like say the
games coming out of early access later
this year yeah so basically they are
we're up to now is we just released our
last sort of major content update in the
sense that you know levels and bosses
and that kind of stuff yeah and now
basically what we're doing is just
working on finishing the game had a lot
of people asking about you know when
you're gonna finish the game so far on
Steam and so the answer to that is in
the next couple of months oh cool
I was gonna say cuz like it was one of
those games where you playing in early
access to I'm thinking myself doesn't
feel like an early access game I'm not
even sure what they could add but you
have been adding stuff like
progressively right yeah yes so
basically since the update we've done
what five six six major updates in terms
of levels boxes all that kind of stuff
cool I'm gonna take that and but I guess
the biggest sort of additions have been
stuff that's come out of the community
in terms of adding new mechanics and
different ways of playing the game so
for example when you started you didn't
have any of this fire damage kind of
stuff you right have any other sort of
poison damage stuff that's all things
that we've added on so I think the last
time I played it was like over the
holidays so I'm trying to I'm trying to
remember like what might be new for me
probably for you if you haven't seen I
guess the last big boss that's gonna be
the latest update that would have come
out so that's what you know like this
whole hand of the king thing so there's
a big guy who's waiting for you which
means there's also the last three levels
mature which are new and then obviously
like it's same thing we do with all the
UH places new new new enemies new
weapons all the kinds of new items and
stuff I'm eager to share tactics
and then again more more of those system
changes so for example I'm not sure if
you would have seen if yeah maybe over
the holidays you would have seen the
foundry update so we completely redid
the balancing of the entire game ok so
we added for example you can see some of
these weapons here a multicolored I
can't afford any of them unfortunately
but that means that you can now play a
lot of different builds for a lot of for
a long period of time was just like
you're gonna take brutality because that
makes sense yeah it's just always the
most viable build sure and now we've
made it so that you can you can mix
things right off and that's where we've
been already working on things so I'm
just mainly about balancing and kind of
adding more variety for a play style
yeah exactly more choices to your place
exactly like I'm playing with something
right now that I would never play really
I'm saying it's like the torch reaches
yeah yeah it's not my choice but you're
doing well yeah so basically I'm just
gonna try and get I've loved that
downward attacks so much the game just
like feels great like I remember right
away when I first started playing it
back like what have been last fall maybe
when I first played it and we were
talking about it on our live show that
just it just feel it immediately feels
good between the - like a - kind of like
I'm one of those people who I prefer
like you know games where I can actually
- and move about as opposed to blocking
and everything yeah that's why I love
the builds in this yeah well so I mean
that's that like that feeling that you
are you talking about something that we
worked on extensively fake for months
and months I'm a lead designer and
getting played for our grandma said he's
a bigger than our kids when it comes to
that kind of things but I don't feel
like exactly I asked
ages on it fixing it great I'm gonna
skip this guy but like you know my
modest contribution to the game was
actually that role so I was playing at
the time
mama Dora and a few of heard of that
memory of what she's like this little 2d
side-scroller but it rings a bell yeah
anyway it's got this roll in it that
felt really good and we used to have a -
and I was like hmm why don't we try this
and so you know the guys at first I can
will say and then they played it tested
Apple like oh that's cool yeah so we put
that in so it's always just about you
know iterating until we find something
that feels lighter and say just you pick
it up me like not cool one of the one of
the obvious compare I mean everybody
compares stuff to Dark Souls nowadays
like anytime anytime you have like
deliberate combat people compared to the
Dark Soul even though you know like
other games do it but as far as like you
know refilling your health flasks that's
kind of like something did you actually
draw inspiration from Dark Souls where
those comparisons well-founded or was
just one of those things were a little
we're categorizing it like that well
that's that's actually something even
even we ourselves categorize that sort
of like that at the in the beginning of
because we were paying a lot of
attention to that sort of deliberate
combat reading the patterns of the
monsters and and making sure that when
you move forward you're gonna think
carefully about how you do that or isn't
a 2d plane right exactly obviously
redefined so more like you know the guys
from salt and sanctuary
all right so there was there was that
sort of reference in terms of the
difficulty in terms of particularly the
way the weapons change your combat style
so each weapon or item throwing this
burning torch around right now that's
that doesn't play anywhere near anywhere
near like for example those sandals that
I've just picked up sure and it doesn't
play anywhere near like a deep road so
having said that as we've as we've
advanced we move
/ away from from that kind of Dark Souls
influence right now I sort of think it
would be a little bit unfair of us to
say oh adds Dark Souls like we've
developed an identity your own yeah well
I mean it's just the community they've
come back to us and said you know what
we like we like moving fast okay there's
not many of that in doghouses
yes I mean being in early access what's
it like being able to get feedback on
you know in real time
amazing yeah that's that's one of the
principal reasons that we did it to be
honest is because you know it's a
roguelike game so you're gonna be dying
retrying dying to retry and so that
balances is everything yes game and we
knew that we couldn't do that ourselves
all right we're gonna need that as how
many people are at motion tween working
on that's uh so the fool like the the
actual development team is seven so two
graphic artists yeah Laura grandmas and
and then you've got you know like myself
and the rest of the guys taking care of
all the extra you know day-to-day stuff
of the studio yeah but no getting pumped
all right well yeah so seven of them and
and I mean it's hot like sense the the
lead gameplay designer and so he'll be
by itself like in front of spreadsheets
like looking at always like Kerr like
inner lines which I was exactly he's
trying to work out like scratching his
head and then we'll have people who've
played the game for hundreds of hours
and way more there because we don't have
time to play the game and so they'll
come to us and be like you know what we
noticed like when you hit this like lost
level here that it takes you about 3540
minutes to get into the run if you're
playing with this particular item that's
you know it's really just sort of not
viable I'll show you
and that information you know unless we
were actually gonna sit and play ten
half an hour runs ourselves we just
can't get so it could be you know
working on the game exactly sure so
that's that's that's wonderful I mean
just watching it and like seeing you
know obviously you got the the upgrade
that lets you grow those vines to climb
up
it's it's tough because when like
especially when like a a game from a
smaller team who doesn't the marketing
of like a triple a company when it comes
out I think the easiest way to Dement a
game is someone is to compare it and
like categorize it right like oh this is
like Dark Souls then I feel like a
Metroidvania but like now it's funny
when I mentioned dead cells I don't have
to compare it they are just like oh [ __ ]
that's coming out in a few months that's
awesome like it does things do develop
an identity of their own and it's nice
to not have to just like compare at each
at each of its aspects to its
inspirations but it's only it's holy its
own thing
yeah well that's that's something that
home again like one of them we started
developing the game but we're sort of
thing can happen well why did I do this
build aside so when we started out
developing were like how can we explain
what this is to people really quickly
yeah and so you know one of the
developers he was like it's like you
know we're saying oh it's like a rogue
well I was sort of Metroidvania aspects
into it into it and he's like why we
just call it a rogue Vania and we're all
it was one of those kind of money yeah
yeah guys brilliant of a race and so we
did that and but now as the game's
progressed we sort of feel like you know
we can we have less and less of a claim
towards the title Metroidvania yeah it's
very much a roguelike game now in like
five years maybe people will say dead
cells mania yeah something like that
it's become its own thing yeah and now
we're kind of like we're lucked into say
oh it's it's this type of game sure
and we're gonna more to say it's it's
dead so this fast-paced action
platformer oh if you will these guys go
to school for me before there anything
else any other aspects that changed
through feedback like you said it you
found out through feedback that people
really liked the agile aspects of it and
how you can actually move faster any any
other major tenants that did change or
was it kind of just like all about
iteration any major tenants that changed
I think potentially yeah that like that
Metroidvania aspect of it initially when
we when we first started out we wanted
to do some stuff whereby those dangers
whereby we were going to for example
limit certain weapons to certain areas
and try and give it more of that
exploration II metroidvania feel and
then it's just like you find something
that works and so you go with it and
we've just left that out and focus much
more on okay we're gonna randomize
everything a lot more and we're getting
give you the option to create any kind
of build no matter where you are in the
goal I'm doing welfare also talking yeah
I can't really do that well well we're
actually were actually working on out
between you me and the doorposts the the
switch version of the game Wow awesome
so I've been I've been extensively
testing yeah that version was again so
I've been playing in quite a bit
recently how does it play like handheld
it's pretty cool yeah I'm not gonna lie
it's very close tough when like a skill
based game goes the handheld because you
don't have the same balance you do with
a controller yeah it's always tough to
work that out yeah I mean there is that
question with the switch because it's
it's in your hand differently yeah I
mean like obviously I prefer playing
with the pro pro controller or with the
joy cons in their little sheriff mini
drakonia majiggy even Dark Souls come in
switched soon it's gonna be interesting
you have various about that I'll
probably I'll almost always play that in
the pro controller but who knows you
play holiday last year yeah yeah like
that too I mean you're you're you
mentioned salt and sanctuary which is a
great game that would I think song
sanctuary and dead cells have a few more
similarities but as far as like
Metroidvania aspect
in a two-year-old Hollow night was
hollow nights more like open-ended and
maybe not as focused definitely not as
focused on combat but I loved how the
night yeah I think well I mean a lot of
people have made that sort of comparison
obviously to like games that have done
really well coming out at the same time
we shot similar claims the fame of while
a Metroidvania in there seems like there
is like a mini Renaissance of Metroid
mania you know like I mean game
development so cyclical and like games
like this will come out and everybody
will be back into them and then games
like this will come out but it's nice to
see these doing well yeah well I think
it's funny actually like from from my
perspective I'm sitting around looking
at games and following the press over
time and sort of thinking how I really
want to play this type of game and it's
interesting to see how few of those
games there actually are when you when
when you start to look yeah get uh-oh
what happened that was outrageous the
headshot I don't know what the heck that
was but I'm not happy about it man he
like one shot me okay
oh I must have like in two times damaged
oh yeah I do I have a double damage so
yeah I think how I know it and this I
have some kind of similarities but then
that's like I said like goes back to I
was saying about us moving away from
saying war on them yeah there you go
because we really focused on that
roadway like you know at Holland I'm you
die you go back a little bit and sure
come back and you read through that part
yeah yeah whereas now I'm starting the
whole thing again okay yeah but it helps
if this is more combat oriented because
it's just like it's you might be
starting over but still then it's still
like fun right at the beginning it's not
something like you're not progressing
through something that might feel kind
of like a grind
yeah well and that's that's one of the
big differences between the game and
something that we've definitely put a
lot
the Sun was to say okay
hallow night is classic with
Metroidvania in the sense that when you
start out you're very limited in what
you can do it you know you've got this
little sword that doesn't reach very far
you can easily knocked back where as
dead cells goes in the opposite
direction in their cells right from the
very first run you're always like whoa I
can move on fast I'm dangerous you know
and that's that's a clear design choice
something that we really we put the
emphasis on and said okay well this is
what we want to make our game like yeah
so that's where we're from that's other
things
so yeah unfortunately might be coming up
on all the time we have but uh yeah I'm
excited so you said like toward the end
of the year you're gonna actually be
releasing the game in full outside of
early access yep so towards the end of
the full version outside of our access
we'll also be bringing the game to
Nintendo's Ridge PlayStation show war
Xbox one cool so it's also all really
simultaneously yeah every Fossum comment
sometimes well I mean unless we stop
something a really badly but well it's
coming along nicely here's hoping it
doesn't happen but uh awesome thanks so
much Steve for him on Jonas dead cells
of course I'm like I said a lot of
people like especially if they follow
GameSpot off and they probably play this
we played it a lot and everything but we
really appreciate you coming out to show
us while you're in town for GDC and I
know you'll be around the indie mix
later so people can catch that as well
but um yeah in the meantime later on
this year to be able to play dead cells
outside of early access on switch ps4
Xbox one PC yep pretty much any way you
want to play games to me it's not on
mobile but well why would this be but
anyway Steve thanks so much for coming
on showing us we really appreciate it
and uh if you're watching stick around
we're gonna be coming on with two more
games on our games by indie mix stream
thanks so much for joining we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone we are back with the
GameSpot's indie mix livestream we are
having the developers that are in town
for GDC onto our stream we are lucky
enough that they're all in one place
this week I'm here with Rufus from 11
bit studios hello we're gonna be showing
off frost Punk again but I'm
particularly excited about right now the
released Windows sometime in 2018 later
in the year actually we already have the
date so it's 24th of April awesome so
not too far up so you're showing off the
game like a what a month four comes out
so yeah we're just gonna start a new
game and so what's the elevator pitch
for this game you know like steampunk
city building is like what the tagline
is but how would you describe the game
yeah I would like to describe it as a
society survival game okay because it
has city building mechanics but your
main goal is to survive as a society
okay that's the main idea basically okay
so yeah we're starting off from the new
game and so would you say it's more like
is it even a post apocalypse or is it
kind of is it just like an alternate
reality I guess yeah it's like an
alternative history set in 19th century
gosh yeah that's why we have the
steampunk setting but the steampunk
setting also made sense for us because
how do you fight with Colt right you are
fighting with something hot something
that that can generate heat so you are
fighting with steam basically okay
it looks really good like how many
people are working on the game our
studio is up to 100 people right now
from which like 80 I would say is
working on first bank yeah gotcha
so just the beginning of the game
actually this is like a pretty exclusive
build this is the first time we are
showing the the new and the newest built
around to the people and the main goal
at the beginning always is to gather
some coal because you need the coal to
generate to activate the generator and
so you people basically won't freeze to
death right Sherea and as your main
resource at least at the beginning yeah
we also have wood and steel which are
more like construction resources kasha I
see you have like our settlers would you
call them or your your people come out
of the main tower you have three types
of people so you have normal workers
which are which can do almost everything
okay
you have engineers which are fit for
more I would say professional works like
in the workshop more scientific stuff
okay and then you have children which
can be used as workers but you may also
choose to protect them and not use them
to do any job there's some like morality
choices to it oh yeah there's just a lot
of morality choices gotcha
we will get into that right away oh I
see let's go the way they're moving
through the snow they actually have to
clear the snow out yeah I like that what
I'm doing here is I'm building a road so
they can make it faster okay because the
the snow path will get covered in snow
when it's snowing great sure makes sense
I see like a time of day changing with
the shadow yeah
we have full day and night circle okay
at night it's getting colder sure you
have the heat map here which I will show
in a second when we activate the
generator you can see the difference
then actually we already have some calls
so we can start the generator
gotcha
so now when you go to the heat map you
can see that this area is oh think so no
you saw with your people I'm assuming is
it like they can go out and code for a
certain amount of time but at some point
they need to come back and warm up or
does that like kind of radiate outward
is that an area of effect yeah basically
it's like an area of effect you can
upgrade it later on we have different
steam levels different arrange settings
you can also put your generator or the
on the overdrive during like very cold
nights yes so people will survive for
then you need to avoid you know this bar
going up because this is the stress
level and if it goes to 100% your
generator will explode and that
basically ends the game that's we have
to be very very careful with that here
you can see some quests that we are
receiving because the main campaign is
quite storage event quest driven so it's
not like open box sandbox city-builder
you have to do new stuff all the time
you have to keep progressing gotcha
and you sound assuming you have like
teams of writers on the team right that
word yeah awesome
so there's main story and there is also
some some like lower bits that you can
discover later on all right what i'm
doing here is i'm building a hunter's
hut so so the build plots are like radio
circle around its our cool again it
makes sense
because you want to keep as close to the
generator as possible yeah and also just
building along that road speed it up or
help workers get to there faster or okay
yes and here is our first choice our
people are asking us to build some
shelters because they are freezing to
death in the cold yeah so I'm deciding
to give them some shelter so I only have
to provide shelters for half of the
people that I have and I'm in my society
right now
what I would have used that more coal if
you got shelter for everybody or a
certain resource I would have to provide
shelters for all the people which is
kind of difficult at the beginning you
don't have enough resources to put I
don't know ten tents and I gotta even
though I only have resources for three
so it still won't be enough okay
so well the entirety of this playthrough
be based around this specific generator
or can you branch and make other ones or
is it you're trying to revolve around
this one yeah in the main campaign you
are revolving around the main generator
here but there will be different
scenarios available in game we are not
spoiling them yet so I'm not telling
anything at this moment but there will
be different scenarios in the game cool
and again when you are making some
decisions you need to be sure that you
are making them and you are not being
like pressed by by your people right
yeah it's like the burden of being a
waiter kind of right
it's interesting you don't often see RTS
games combined with survival but like
now that I'm seeing it it's like did you
have like it inspiration for like
where'd you get the inspiration for
obviously this seems pretty unique part
of the inspiration is this world of mine
our previous game is still a survival
game about small group of people right
here we want to like widen the scope
yeah so now we have a whole society a
whole city but we also you know we're at
some steampunk ebooks we watch some
steampunk movies okay we also read some
like logs from people going to the
mountains and trying to survive in the
high mountains so it's partly inspired
by that as well yeah I see you're yes so
you're managing the morale down here
just content and hope yeah okay so you
can also see the reasons why they are
discontent and why they are hopeful
basically some yeah I'm assuming at all
maybe they just content their reasons
for this content well potentially grow
later on and I think that's one of your
main obstacles later on okay so that's
why we also have the book of laws to set
up new roles in the city okay so a lot
of people when I watch like streamers
playing FirstBank they usually send
children to work yeah so I will show the
different option here to build and
provides child shelters and again this
is something that will give hope to your
people
okay whereas if you put them to work
you'll get more resources but maybe this
can get what girl
okay exactly cool you will have like a
more human resource but still it's not
safe for them to work right yeah and
what you are doing here is usually
there's in games like that you have a
lot of micromanagement like in Warcraft
or Starcraft
here you're rather managing groups of
people so I'm you know asking people to
work in the hunters hat or gather the
coal but I'm not selecting each unit and
you know putting them to work I'm just
selecting groups of people so it's still
more like a city builder management game
and not like an RTS sure the classic
sense I would say
yes so when you mention the campaign
will there be specific characters or is
it kind of when you said there's like
there's an actual is there like a story
revolving around groups like you just
mention or like will they very specific
characters in like the main story
revolves or revolves around why the
earth is frozen
Katherine okay you try to discover why
it's frozen but your main goal in
general is to survive okay so you are
doing everything to survive right and by
everything I already mean everything
because there are some laws regarding
cannibalism for example okay gotcha or
later on you can choose a path of order
which can lead to like totalitarian
state basically which is not nice to
your people but it's interesting to see
like what kind of choices what kind of
like leader people will become right it
might yeah and then you know if you're
just trying to be completely good all
the time that might not be best for
survival that's basically the main
question that we are asking what kind of
leader will you become when you're
pushed to the limit
[Applause]
very cool
I love those the tracks in the snow as
opposed to sue know just being aesthetic
if it's actually like slowing them down
and yeah so presumably lay around the
base will start radiating outward being
bigger and bigger yeah you you will
upgrade the generator to have the more
heat outside you can expand the city
are there any outside forces in the
world aside from the cold like animals
or some sort of things that that people
need to defend against they are but
usually it's like quest based during the
exploration phase I don't know if we
will have enough time to show the
exploration phase here but I will try
and to make it work but for example you
can meet some bears attacking people out
there and then you have a choice to
engage the Bears or try to escape and of
course your decision will influence the
story in some way okay
but that the main enemy so to speak is
is the called government overwhelming
cult all the time
so here I am building the workshop which
is like your main science area thanks to
this you will be able to discover new
technologies of upgrades and whatnot
yeah exactly
how this is the technology yeah oh so if
all the different categories what I am
going for here is the beacon because I
want to show the exploration I may be
rushing some things here so yeah but we
may die eventually or some that I just
want to show it different behind in
mechanics doing during this playthrough
so it is like a common thread right in
this war of mine it was often asking you
to make difficult choices right as
survivors during the war until like you
know like until the ceasefire was called
in that game what you don't know when
it's gonna come you're just trying to
make the best choice as you can it's
interesting to see you rather than
managing a smaller group of survivors
now you're doing similar things but with
a massive you know settlement in a city
that you're trying to build up
[Applause]
yeah so another decision that I'm going
to make because it's really needed let's
try to activate the emergency shift
which will make people work during whole
day and whole night okay it's the whole
24 hours yeah so they want to be happy
about that
Midas content will rise yeah but we
really need the resources to you know
survive so let's push some limits here
so the discontent said lack of shelter
and the emergency shift yeah - emergency
[ __ ] so you have to balance that all the
time
it's almost like that you know like
probably just because the city building
in the leadership aspects but there are
elements of like a civilization game
right but except not turn bass right
this is real time and also much darker
and more grim than a civilization game
would be I mean you can nuke people in
Civilization but you know that the
choices aren't always pushing you to
your moral limits I wouldn't say and we
always like to show the human
perspective right that's why each
character hero name has its status
family status it's all here
basically those names are very steampunk
gauge in Churchill and Owen have arrived
yeah so we had like a name generator for
london-based
English names yeah LC which we had to
tweak not to generate names like Harry
Potter for example you have quite some
copyright stuff yeah
so let's speed things up imagines to
shift again to make people unhappy right
about three emergency shifts listen it's
not easy living can approximate away
still enjoyed reminds me of what was
that the movie the Korean movie has
snowpiercer appears yeah yeah
actually pretty good movie yeah one of
the inspirations for some stuff yeah
yeah
finally we have the beacon and soon we
will be able to build it
I will not activate another emergency
she does know what happens if their
discontent reaches for the full bar
basically it's like a failed state okay
the same as the hope drops to zero you
need to avoid some dis stuff so your
choices are leading to some okay not so
cool results like a heart attack or what
was likely a heart attack yeah okay so
let's let's go with more good option
here not to generate more discovered
practice again and then you can decide
what to do with the corpses right I've
actually build the cemetery or should we
have like a massive corpse disposal Wow
and again this will influence the ending
of the game so if you season there
obviously you know like but you're also
you know increasing discontent the are
decreasing hope
so you're trying to prevent discontent
from reaching the max you're trying to
prevent hope from reaching the minimum
presumably is there like a population
count that you're trying to keep pretty
high 10 okay if that goes down is that a
foul state as well all the way down yeah
basically yes actually people can die if
they get sick or during the events
during the exploration events what we
can finally do is to build the beacon
this is something really cool I wanted
to show you when we are building this
kind of important buildings you will
have this kind of cool animation like
again in Civ games when you build like a
as Wonder and yes it is something like
that
cool it's a very important moment
because before this phase you are kind
of blind you are only in this hole now
you have eyes outside the hole and again
send expeditions so just like a huge
moment for your city and as isolated
yeah
Wow and now this declaration yeah it's
way bigger than I thought I'd be so at
the beginning I only have two locations
to explore but every time you explore
one you will get more to explore all
right yeah so it's getting bigger and
bigger all the time and as soon as we
can I was and we can send them already
send an expedition to to our last
expedition some people were lost here so
we will try to rescue them it will again
it will take 10 hours to get there for
our scouts so in the meantime you can
still manage your city do they have to
like the ice climbers kind of to get out
of this hole so to speak okay
yeah later on maybe there will be
different types of you know different
ways to get out you said you're reading
some books about people that went to the
mountains and whatnot try to survive do
you read about like the Donner Party in
America in the write the Rocky Mountains
there's this party of travelers who I
kind of I'm sure I haven't read it
personally but maybe some guys from our
team did yeah cuz overall this just
reminds me that
yes of that map like because you run
into other other cities they're being
built you could like spread out your
like to build more cities with other
generators or you kind of focused on
this one you got to focus on this one
yeah you can find different stuff I
don't want to spoil too much yeah it's
like story based so I will show you some
things but not not the bigger ones sure
we still need to provide the shelter
which I will try to do now
and this is the thing you have to all
the time you have to remember about
different stuff you have to remember
that you need enough coal to keep the
generator running you have to remember
about all the quests you have to
remember that your expedition is
somewhere out there yeah you have to
remember to make new laws because it's
useful right - what I like to do is I
will give you an example and chilled
shelters seems useless at the beginning
because you are not getting anything
from it right here some help or
something very small reward but later on
thanks to this you can teach children to
be medical apprentices they will have a
help in the medical posts and it is
really useful because a lot of people
get sick later on this awesome
so even like even some of the better you
know like some of them you know like
more objectively good morality decisions
will pay off if you're like in the long
run they may pay off or might might and
I yeah yeah it's not so easy
yeah so unfortunately we might be
running up on our time we have must have
anything like last minute you want to
show us why yeah I could show you I will
speed up the time and I will show the
the exploration even though so we get
the idea how it looks sure
I love the changing weather table it
smelling like that it's getting even
worse later on there's like a four-year
cycle supposedly yeah I mean the game
will last set them out of days so it's
not like months or years yeah here's the
exploration event and basically you get
like a small bits of lore each time you
explore a new a new site and then you
can decide what to do should you explore
further around maybe you want to ask of
the survivors to the city okay I'm a
good guy I will score them it will
shorten the trip for them so I can get
new survivors that means new workers for
me new engineers new resources
potentially what would happen if you
just sent them what I asked for
they could die on the way and it will
take them longer to get back home
basically but you would have been able
to keep your explorers out or something
Ares they could go further on different
project different sites cool so those
will happen periodically stuff like that
like exploration events when you send
out expeditions yeah cool awesome
unless I'm coming back right now yeah I
really love the artwork that comes up
here and we have really a lot of
illustrations like that there's hundreds
of them so awesome well Rufus thank you
so much for showing us Frost Ponca like
you said I wanted people have been
streaming and already been able to watch
it but uh sort of loving bit Studios of
who made this war of mine as well as the
expansion that came out for it and it
was really great to have you on and I
hope you have a good GC we can thank so
much and remind me of one more time
April 24th
yes exactly ra's Punk on you know pc on
pc yeah awesome thanks so much Rufus and
if you're watching right now stick
around with one more game to show you
million whare we'll be right back after
the break so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
indie mix livestream I'm Mike my Hardy
if you've been here all day we are on
the last game but not the least of
course I'm here with Pat from Good
Shepherd publishing and we're gonna be
playing mill and waar I'm gonna be
playing it actually Pat you're gonna
kind of lead me around so elevator pitch
before we get into the game what uh what
can we be expecting from mill and waar
okay melena waar is a top-down 2d action
game
okay that's inspired by sort of like
1970s crime films okay awesome so if
you've ever seen like caliber 9 or
almost human you'll definitely recognize
how similar themes with this game cool
so let's jump right in and you said
won't be playing the first chapter it
was about 15 minutes mm-hmm okay cool
yeah so this is a little intro where
you'll meet the character you'll be
playing as okay and then after that
we'll jump in the first chapter okay
awesome yeah it's gonna be heading into
the bar there sorry John Luke should be
bringing up b-roll at some point
actually I'll hold on yeah there we go
okay cool guys all right I like first
yeah I got some sick hair I see oh yeah
so this is a 1970s Milan okay and if
you're not familiar with any of the
films mentioned earlier the devs are
also big Tarantino fans nice so you'll
has this place out you'll definitely see
where they drew some inspiration from
okay so you said someone I'm looking for
in the bathroom yes okay it's clean back
so it's largely story-driven we're going
through this 1970s Milan yeah so it's um
Title II it was like story-driven okay
and this is what you need to character
you'll be playing as awesome so
basically just what just happened was a
rival mob tried to take you out
unfortunately they picked the room stall
gotcha and I was standing on the toilet
exactly awesome gotcha
sweet yes and now this is Piero his line
of work is in the organized crime okay
filled so yeah I like the credits open
credits over this - yeah yeah it's a
very it's very it's a mature game yeah
but with some pretty wild themes okay as
I see so this first chapter introduces
you to some of the gameplay mechanics
first of which will be stealth and then
it'll introduce the shooting mechanics
okay but basically you are going to go
after one of the top lieutenants of the
gang that just tried to take you out
okay and that top lieutenant is known to
frequent a certain brothel okay so
that's where this first chapter will
take us Tasha going into here
these guys know each other yeah so um
this guy here works for the boss that
you also work for okay so it's kind of
like a rival gotcha
but this is your boss here
a lot of strong Italian names oh yeah I
love that like every time he makes a
statement just lame yeah it's down the
table
ullscreen shucks yeah no so they were
pushing into their turf
[Music]
gotcha so I might like largely a hit man
yeah yeah go friar and then this will be
the first rival mob member you'll be
taking out gotcha which once you get to
actually fighting against her that's
where the the boss battle mechanic kind
of kicks in okay so let's see you hop on
the Vespa Cruiser a the brothel
it's very Italian yeah yeah and I mean
um staying true to those Italian crime
films like the chase sequences are
ridiculous then a guy using you'll see
you'll see at the end of this nice I so
here we are at the brothel so that's a
target okay she frequents this place yes
this is the brothel which she can be
found up quite often okay this guy oh
yes are you saying guy right
yeah they've cruise up the stairs to the
left so this is where it introduces the
first sort of gameplay mechanic which is
stealth okay so as you held left trigger
go crouch okay and then you can roll and
then when you get close to a player just
repeatedly tap a and go choke them out
gotcha
I love to spiral yeah well some stuff
goes with lines yeah like I said it's a
very mature game so if you hold left
trigger yet and I knew you got it up
here going all the way up
[Music]
now am I going through them just
distracted so yeah makes it easier to
take him down now here we go so from
this gentleman we're gonna try and find
out where their top lieutenant is let's
do like the handler or whatever yeah so
he's trying to be a little sly with us
right now then nice in the hand yeah
chopsticks yeah never mind
some of the sharpest chopsticks into
yeah so you got it
that's a no she's at Akal
[Music]
and then just to further explain the the
crouching king so as long as you're
crouching find an object
you're a detective so that will come
into play when gunfire shirts gotcha
nice yeah ah there's the red door all
right all right here we go
oh my god you appear she's not wonder
where she is
yeah let's just check in here what could
possibly go wrong
[Music]
so there's our guys so this introduces
the shooting mechanic which will be a
big part of the game so right triggers
to shoot and then right bumper is to
reload and as you'll see like we can
take damage it'll sort of create this
old film oh yeah
aesthetic on the sides and as long as
you're in cover you'll slowly regenerate
the help gotcha
[Music]
hey oh nice
sweet and shut up here oh whoops no I
want to get behind that yeah so as long
as you're behind cover you won't take
damage but as soon as you start shooting
it does leave you vulnerable
okay I got shot you hit I'll get away
this did those I think those are the
most terrifying
yeah they're I named one I gather you've
steak knife yeah
damn it daddy I like the film
yeah something comes up though yeah so
when you die you just start over right
away
cool intuitive
I got your kiln so fast got passed in
that
[Music]
right now if I'm there you go
[Music]
like I was switched to like you know a
side-scrolling shooter now yeah
I think oh man you'd pick this up
quickly you know the UH yeah the cover
mechanics feel good no man
yeah and so in this you're you just have
the pistol right now which is your base
weapon which you obviously have
unlimited ammunition for but as you
progress you'll pick up other weapons
pick up some projectiles so I got mouth
of cocktails oh that's sweet oh man oh
God
I guess this work gets a little crazy
you just kind of try to survive as long
as you can you'll eventually run out of
ammunition
[Music]
I'll be just in time and who's this
Lucia
so Lucia has been working in the brothel
for a while and she sees an opportunity
with you as a way out okay gotcha she
become my main character I'm assuming
yeah so this is another mechanic in the
game if you've seen any shoot street
signs
you can shoot those and the bullets will
ricochet and have pretty much always
hidden enemy cool
[Music]
other streets on earth actress on yeah
the ladies of the knives are fearless
Ian's a horrifying thing yeah I guess
straight Sciences
she has got a plan
Oh show me so this is um the first stage
of where the boss battle starts okay so
in order to defeat are you gonna shoot
the street signs
Oh
okay the essence that this one's that
it's kind of top it throws you in the
fire and literally over there
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a nice and she's bleeding quite a lot
so she escapes however it's a back-up
plan shake this thing yeah this is our
chase vehicle oh yeah sweet
[Applause]
all right all 25 horsepower
which is the back shin yeah so yeah
you're controlling both the shooting in
the vehicle and it'll get kind of crazy
cuz yeah certain cars will trying to
attack you and then there was also ya
guys on bikes will be shooting at you as
well
[Music]
that's construction - yeah horse
and the fruit stands yeah in each a
sequence there's always a fruit stand
that gets destroyed oh man this does not
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah this is a this is sort of the last
part of the boss battle okay that's
probably the trickiest bit
[Applause]
yeah so I'm trying out this shot and
also not the crashing it's only things
yeah
so one of the things that does make the
game easier is that you can play
cooperative it has couch co-op oh cool
okay which M you know obviously makes
things quite a bit easier sure yeah all
right so now let's avoid crashing this
time gonna feel like that's what these
yeah the guys on the bikes are sort of
priority number one a taking them out
ahead of doing the most damage okay it's
cars key
[Music]
nice ass kid look at the sandwich yeah
that's my divert each time
of more first things
I think I'm doing better time yeah
you're doing once you get past this part
these on the best weather aggressive
[Applause]
strong is the best cooking talk music to
to get so good yeah it's got that like
seven seven 70s Milan so the music
definitely captures that 70s funk sure
so yeah you this has a checkpoint cops
are gonna try and pull over the floor
over but a doctor no match Sam Vettori
is that a person or a place
[Music]
you said I did yeah that's a great hit
[Applause]
nice
yeah so this word gets a little tricky
she's gonna try to ram you okay
and it's very difficult to avoid but
once she hits you you can usually
recover
nice
[Applause]
yeah so now as long as you can kind of
stay out of her direct line of sight
okay should be good
[Applause]
it's very 70 van - oh yeah
[Applause]
so close
nice yeah once you get the once you get
the hang of the reloading and it has
become second nature but you pick up
quickly can you play this one Baskin
keyboard mmm okay that's gonna sign up
seem like it with the cursor wasn't me
dying from the traffic cones yeah sweet
so that yeah that was Chapter one gives
you an introduction to a couple of
characters in the game they'll be
playing Anson Tony chapters um a lot I
actually don't know there's three acts
within the game okay his plays different
characters cool and yeah we doesn't set
release date yet but it'll be coming out
very soon
cool could it be coming to PlayStation 4
Xbox one Steam and Nintendo switch
awesome thanks so much for coming in and
showing us Miller noir form I eat a lo
games the Talos game that correctly yeah
cool so that's like a 70s crime thriller
set in Milan but yeah so they'll be
coming up soon on the platform's patches
mention but everybody thank you so much
for joining us today for the indie mix
livestream we are lucky enough to be
right down the street from where all
these talented and intelligent
developers are gathering throughout the
week here in San Francisco California
obviously if you're stopping by we'll
have a bunch of these videos I'll try to
you know get them up and published on
YouTube GameSpot if you want to watch
them again but before we end it we're
gonna have Justin Woodward from the
indie mix who is developing on stuff
easy to come on at the last minute just
to kind of talk about what he makes us
doing here this week so stick around for
that and we'll have Justin on
momentarily
thanks for coming and stop by Pat thank
you month so much thank you
yeah and I'll see you around this week
but again stick stick around for indie
mix justin Woodward's gonna come on a
talk quick but thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back I'm Mike thank
you so much for joining us as we show it
off all these indie games Here I am here
with Justin Woodward from the media
India exchange and I wanted to just you
wanted to come on and kind of talk about
what a new mix is doing here all week
during GDC and kind of what your your
mission is and everything and in
supporting these any death so I'll just
hand it off to you
cool cool I just want to say much
gratitude for gamespot for showing these
amazing games these guys really really
appreciate kind of the exposure because
they're always looking for you know a
way to market their games because
they're they're you know grinding
working on their games all the time and
don't like always have the time the
chance to mingle and stuff so I mean
we're here we have an event tonight the
mix meeting in the exchange and you know
we're here I'm a developer too so if you
guys didn't know that I we started this
because a few of my friends and myself
we're trying to figure out ways to
market our games because like I said we
don't always have the time to like go
out and pitch and like talk to you know
people from GameSpot or impressed and
whatnot
so we're gonna be showing 50 games
tonight they're gonna be able to mingle
with each other talk about their games
to the press talk about their games to
like publishers and and different
possible partners and there will be
first party like Nintendo and
PlayStation there so we're there to just
basically like help create relationships
like just help network and work with
indie devs to get the exposure you know
that they need to get their game out
into the world so that's pretty much it
yeah we had a good time today you guys
play black future 88 Noah
milah noir Frost Punk dead cells and
carrion I think I named them all six of
them
yeah and then of course later on and be
streaming from the mix itself will be
hosting a live stream of about six more
games right like obviously that's not
the only games that are here but you
know some like that we wanted to really
show on a live stream that'll be on
twitch facebook youtube I think right
now is just cool twitch intuition
Facebook so you can go to
Media index change if you don't follow
them on Twitter let's Rob the best way
to get news I'm assuming yeah through
that so we'll be announcing showing off
the link later I'm actually pretty
excited I'll be hosting that as well be
helping you guys out there lis excited
now it's gonna be a good one finally
play some of the games I just played
milling to orbit and you get to play any
other one so I'm looking forward to
playing those tonight so that'll be at 8
p.m. Pacific we'll kick it off yeah
awesome
but outside of that thank you so much to
everybody who joined whether is on
YouTube twitch or GameSpot to see some
of these these nd games that we have to
show off and like Justin said you know
like when they're busy making these
awesome games some of the teams are too
small to really market too much so
that's kind of where we get to you know
show some of our favorites off and it
was from a selfish standpoint it's
really fun for me to be able to me and
John Luke to be able to pick out which
ones we want to show but uh you know
luckily we get to see a few more later
tonight so if you are around check that
out if you want to catch up on these
games or recommend people checking out
the gameplay we'll have these up on
YouTube and GameSpot or I myself will
probably break them out and be able to
watch these after the fact but Justin
thanks so much for coming on you know
thanks okay and we'll see you later and
then uh all people joining on GameSpot
thank you so much for joining and in the
meantime will it be streaming sea of
thieves later unless I'm horribly
mistaken sorry hey if I am but I'm
pretty sure we're streaming see if
thieves
it just servers went alive too at 2:00
p.m. so Nick who won't shut up about the
game will be playing it but anyway thank
you so much for stopping by to watch the
indie mix livestream we'll see you
around
[Music]